wait a minute this is not you're young I
just looked I said who is that beautiful
I know come on I I cannot
what is happening dad listen my
daughters are growing up and it's
fantastic she just finished a movie
she just had 14 points 21 rebounds and
16 blocks against the boys you know in
basketball so I'm just a man
this cannot be a better night I think
Michael B Jordan from the bottom I think
Brian Stevenson our director Destin
Michael crating I think Nigeria curtain
all I think Toby immigrant Warner
Brothers my team James Barnett of Rick
going Chuck with Chico I'm doing my
speech now but this is this is beautiful
and a beautiful project people
responding so well in the A+ CinemaScore
people love it people really love it you
know I just heard a little bird told me
that Henry Winkler just came up and
asked for your phone number what are you
and Henry about to do man you know the
funds we bout to get it I used to tell
the story to him and we could live next
to me he just never talked to me and I
ran into him he says I never lived next
to him
I said I would tell everybody for years
I've been telling me was that I never
left but he came to my sister's we do a
Down syndrome Global down surge maybe he
was there this past year just so we
don't go hang up okay let's brag on I'm
gonna let your girls brag on you real
quick how proud are you guys of dad both
of you all and just and just you know
being here tonight with them and just
how proud
super
[Music]
movies all the time but for just mercy
it was really special that was like that
was one of the first times I've cried
[Music]
you know I feel like my dad is so
multifaceted like when we do our show
beaches am that's the you know
entertainer life with a party guy and
then to see him in this role completely
transform the drama of it and the depth
of his performance was incredible and I
love that people get to see how lucky
faceted he is and you're such a unique
talent and you know when your peers say
we see what you're doing Jamie and we
appreciate you and we want to honor you
that's really special when it's your
peers and and like I said we don't do
this for awards we do it for the art but
when he appears recognized you it means
everything because you do what you do to
run into Henry Winkler and have that
moment of walking finish on my man
Leonardo who I was wit last night we was
talking about how great it is to be in
this business so when it's your peers
and it's it's beautiful in it's
bittersweet because at the same time
Bryan Stevenson when he does tirelessly
helping people get off the death row
Walter McMillian how he lived his life
and if you hadn't had a chance to see
the movie please go see it it's really
for them and we will continue to support
eji we're going to be going down there
every year taking the kids down there
making sure people are aware of the
heritage and and just so special today
ok what were you and Leo doing last
night we was out at the Mannheim system
and man we was hanging with uh we was
with us yeah but no actually was that my
god Chuck's birthday Chuck's birthday
party for his his girlfriend and Leo was
there yge perform Tiger perform well
wake you to something watch me go on a
falsetto
he knows like well y'all have a good
time tonight I can't even believe these
are your babies I can't believe it
[Music]
like I said she's got another movie
coming out this key ball and please keep
balling they got clothing line all kinds
of come on now
[Music]